a lot of folks are taking the internet
fuelled idea of storming area 51 where
conspiracy theorists think the
government has aliens on ice as just
clickbait but it appears the US Air
Force is taking these threats seriously
national security correspondent Jennifer
Griffin shows us tonight from the
Pentagon it was a joke but one the Air
Force is taking seriously a Facebook
post an avowed fake designed to get
likes announced a plan to raid the Air
Force Base in Nevada known as area 51
which has been at the center of UFO and
alien conspiracy theories for decades
more than 1 million people have signed
up for the storm area 51 they can't stop
all of us event slated for late
September in which the post declares we
can move faster than their bullets let's
see them aliens it's been enough to
spook the Air Force which doesn't use
the term area 51 to describe the 2.9
million acre live-fire training range
the largest in the United States located
at Nellis Air Force Base in Nevada one
of the many reasons Air Force officials
don't want people to trespass on the
base they are worried some might be
killed quote any attempt to illegally
access military installations or
military training areas is dangerous
there has been renewed interest in UFO
sightings since it was revealed earlier
this year the military has spent 22
million dollars to research UFOs and
announced new classified guidelines for
how its pilots should report them last
month the Navy briefed several senators
on Capitol Hill about UFO encounters
like this one
[Music]
from a navy f-18 training mission four
years ago off the east coast of the
United States an unidentified aerial
phenomena you have objects that are
doing things maneuvering in weight
without any obvious sign of propulsion
it's not clear the 1.1 million Facebook
followers who said they are going to
storm area 51 are real and not Russian
bots breath Jennifer Griffin at the
Pentagon Jennifer thank you